ariel béret snack bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans la matinale d'air france
on le disait nouvelle réunion du conseil
d accord sur les droits de propriété
intellectuelle de l'eau omc à genève
pourquoi jusqu'à maintenant l'union
européenne ou encore le royaume uni la
suisse se sont toujours opposés à la
levée des brevets du vaccin que contre
le coc vide quels sont les arguments
avancés
alors les arguments sont d'abord les
besoins des pays
l'afrique n'est pas ne semble pas dans
le monde la victime la plus touchée 1
les locaux vides dax surtout concerné en
terme de mortalité l'amérique du sud
l'europe les états unis donc il est
possible que la nouvelle directrice
générale de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce et en tant que première femme
africaine se pose la question de la
moralité du libre échange des vaccins
mais la levée des brevets est un faux
problème parce que ce n'est pas en
levant les brevets des vaccins qu'on va
améliorer
l'accessibilité des vaccins ça veut dire
qu'en fait il faut les mois il ya aussi
sur place de pouvoir les produire c'est
ça
oui les moyens et surtout la compétence
on peut se demander pourquoi la plupart
des des vaccins ont sont déjà dans le
domaine public alors qu'il n'y a
quasiment pas de vaccin générique c'est
parce que il est très difficile de
produire des vaccins ça demande des
compétences très particulières des
cultures du virus des cultures de deux
bactéries des contrôles qualité
extrêmement importante n'oublions pas
qu'on s'adresse à des clients finaux qui
sont les personnes saines donc il ne
faudrait pas
tolérer des démarches de de tolérance
qui serait inacceptable pour des
populations scène et donc il est très
difficile de produire des vaccins le
meilleur exemple c'est peut-être la
fièvre jaune on connaît ce vaccin est
dans le domaine public on le connaît
depuis très longtemps on aurait besoin
théoriquement de vacciner toute la
population
d'afrique et
et d'amérique du sud contre la fièvre
jaune et on n'a pas assez de vaccins
contre la fièvre jaune et aucun
génériqueurs ne s'est lancé pour
produire des des génériques de deux
vaccins contre la fièvre jaune eux ce
n'est pas rentable et ne prendra jamais
le risque pourtant dans une tribune
publiée en septembre il y avait cent
quarante huit anciens chefs d'état des
prix nobel qui ont signé un texte en
faveur de la levée de ces brevets il
rappelle que le vaccin était efficace
que si des milliards de personnes y
avaient accès est ce qu'on aurait pu
éviter des morts avec une levée plus
rapide des brevets
je ne pense pas alors le fait que des
chefs d'état signe des tribunes vous
savez ces sondes et des processus
politiques il faut afficher de la
bienveillance affichée de la morale mais
je ne pense pas que ça aurait changé
quoi que ce soit ça prend des mois et
des mois pour construire des nouvelles
usines pour avoir des compétences et
puis qui va s'occuper des essais
cliniques
pour poursuivre en post marketing même
la la la la la tolérance à moyen et à
long termes des nouveaux vaccins ce sont
les les producteurs originaux qui
normalement se sont se porte garant
auprès des états pour produire les
nouvelles informations par des nouvelles
études si des génériqueurs se lance dans
dans la bataille normalement c'était eux
ils n'ont même pas la compétence pour
faire des études cliniques donc
avec ça c'est un package ept c'est un
produit de bonne qualité et surtout de
la formation de bonne qualité autour du
produit voyez ce que disait le 1er
octobre dernier dans un communiqué la
secrétaire générale d'amnesty
international
la cupidité l'emportent sur la vie et
les droits humains ses entreprises et
ses états connaissent actuellement des
perspectives de reprise économique tout
en laissant des millions de personnes
risquer leur vie et leur santé parce
qu'elles n'ont pas accès à un vaccin
salvateur les pays les plus défavorisés
perdre un temps précieux pour protéger
leurs populations
quels sont les liens finalement entre
les états et les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques à une question d'argent
aussi on imagine
oui les questions d'argent dont il faut
pas en vouloir à la responsable
d'amnesty international jouer son rôle
moral et bienveillant bien entendu mais
il n'y a pas seulement une question
d'argent n'oublions pas que astrazeneca
produit et diffuse son vaccin à prix
coûtant à prix coûtant après ces accords
avec l'université d'oxford donc il
serait beaucoup plus
[Musique]
rentable et rapide de 10 mais d'imaginer
deux meilleurs négociations avec les
laboratoires aux originaux par exemple
en travaillant sur de meilleurs accords
pris volume que tu imaginais juste levé
les vaccins et attendre des mois et des
mois que éventuellement des génériqueurs
de deux vaccins se lance dans la
bataille construisent les usines se
lançant des produits à peu près fiable
commercialise les produits se trouve il
ya de grandes chances qu'il arrive après
la bataille là une pandémie n'est pas
fait pour durer éternellement sinon ça
devient une endémie et personne ne sait
ce que va devenir l'épidémie elle peut
s'arrêter du jour au lendemain comme
elle est venue alors les pays riches
avaient jusque-là miser sur le programme
de solidarité qu'au vaccin pour un accès
mondial et équitable au vaccin est-ce
que ça a fonctionné ou pas aujourd'hui
je ne sais pas bon lit je ne connais pas
les détails du programme kovacs mais il
sens que j'ai un permis aux os et aux
pays les plus pauvres d'avoir un
véritable accès au vaccin
oui mais nous n'oublions pas qu'il faut
se tenir compte des besoins des pays est
ce qu'un pays qui a dans le col le covin
n'est pas une priorité de santé publique
a besoin d'une vaccination généralisée
d'un vaccin pour contre le coc vide ce
n'est pas sûr donc ya pas le des pays
pauvres d'un côté les pays riches de
l'autre côté il ya des pays même au sein
des pays riches qui ont des besoins
différents et puis des pays pauvres au
sein des pays pauvres ou émergents qui
ont aussi des besoins différents le
brésil n'a pas le même besoin que
l'afrique subsaharienne à quoi s'attend
finalement aujourd'hui après cette
réunion de de l'om c'est à genève est ce
que une levée des brevets peut-être
possible dès aujourd'hui
il est normal de se poser la question je
ne sais pas quelle décision ici l'on lac
avec des capacités de décision mais
quelle que soit la décision même de
lever des brevets ça ne changera rien à
la
disponibilité organisationnel et
géographique des vaccins merci beaucoup
ariel berry signal pour votre éclairage
ce matin sur rtl franche je le rappelle
vous êtes scientifique franco suisse
spécialiste en santé publique et
économie de la santé